okay
let's place this guy
okay time to play
ferrury is almost ferrari but not quite
close d4 okay let's play the
binoni
d6 bishop is seven yeah b should be five
chunk okay this is sound
i think it's considered to be like
really bad for black
but i i could never really get why
exactly
then i think aronian started to play
like this
as black and uh that was sort of
a relief i mean i'm still pretty sure
it is bad but at least it makes me feel
better that ironian doesn't understand
it either
don't know what i'm doing here
maybe h6 g5 knight g6
trying to be fancy
i guess normally you're supposed to be
doing completely different things block
you
basically try to try to trade this um
stupid bishop from a seven you prepare
some bishop g5
but this is not what i um what i had in
mind for
this game
h5 h4
at least i know what i'm doing what i'm
doing is probably pointless
but i don't know that
okay
so is there some attack
we kind of lost lost the battle at the
queen side but we hope to
to cook up something in the king size
bishop is three
so is there a way to create a threat
probably no
okay let's bring the king to g7 then
okay
then maybe we go queen j8 and queen h7
this move also involves knight h5 by the
way okay let's go knight h5son
so with the queen on d1 knight h5 would
always be mad by bishop xg4 but
now he sort of releases a surprise from
g4
so i can try this
and then after king g1 we'll just play
knight f4
and this way we'll definitely play
knight f4 let me choose the knight
what says this one
i could probably just check my 8 by the
way h takes f takes knight f4
gtx raw cash tools and queen and shade
queen h3
but maybe it is not checkmate anyway i
quite like what we're doing
this way
he's really asking for this checkmate so
h takes f takes
rookish 2 kangas 2 queen in shade
king g1 is only move queen h3
g takes or maybe king of two
yeah unfortunately i think it all wins
there for uh for white
but i really want to play it okay let's
try to prepare it by um by playing
bishop g5
and now i think we're stressing this
yeah so can we play h takes that would
be even better
yeah i guess we can
so if he takes the queens and we just
play rook takes h2 and knight h3
checkmate so he has to play f takes
and we play rook takes h2
takes we go queen and shade
king g1 and then we probably go knight
take c2
at very least yeah i like it
so king of two now loses in the precise
way quinnish two followed by knight
takes
three wins he goes for it
which is sad okay
so now we need to use check matching
straight e3 is hanging be one
hanging as well and black is up material
so it's so good for black
all right yeah this was fancy as well
actually
funny game alright